hey guys I'm just McDonald and you are
tuned into our gamespot news top 5 show
for all of you don't have the time or
perhaps the inclination to listen to me
ray a lot about the gaming news every
day let's get into the highlights em use
of unusual ratings metal gear solid 5
has earned itself a rare sexual violence
warning from the ESRB this is only the
second game to earn itself the content
the scripture although the game is still
considered and M rating overall as for
the instance we're still yet to learn
exactly how Metal Gear Solid depicted
the feature but the description from the
ESRB indicates that an audiophile
playable in game is responsible for the
ratings morning even though no visual
example is included let me know what you
think of this kind of content inclusion
or if you prefer we can just keep
talking about the weird watermelon in
the screenshot mysterious watermelon
this week Phoenix interactive studios is
asking for a hundred thousand dollars to
make a game about Bible stories and some
of you aren't so happy about it I'm not
sure that the description for call of
Abraham just a hunger for God's Word is
helping any but basically what the dev
wants to do is have their single player
RPG involved gamers in specific Bible
stories and deliver a high graphical
fidelity experience the argument seems
to be somewhere between whether the game
actually looks any good and inevitably
if religion has a place in gaming let me
know what you think about this one in
the comments section below SCS rolled
into town this year we heard an awful
lot about steam machines and while you
can find our full round-up on site I'm
here to give you a quick summary like
any good flexible medium the 13 newly
announced boxes are coming in all shapes
sizes and variations of black actually
even that isn't entirely true since
three of them are white the price and
inherently integrated hardware is
varying hugely at this stage from the i
buy power and cyberpowerpc
machines starting at 499 to Falcon
Northwest offering which can set you
back up to six thousand dollars how much
would you want to pay for a steam
machine if you're planning to pick one
up or is it pc all the way for you let
me know in music next gen now current
gen things that we've waited for it
turns out that Sony's acquisition of
Gaikai has culminated in a service
called PlayStation now PlayStation now
he's all set to enable gamers to stream
games from earlier Sony consoles on to
ps4 Vita and a bunch of sony bravia tvs
no titles have been confirmed for the
service as yet apart from the last of us
and beyond which were demoed for the
feature the service is going to be ready
to go in summer of 2014 after us-based
beta at the end of January for my last
story of the day I know we all hate
trolls but this guy taking advantage of
making game and say his name Xbox dine
out is a weird kind of wonderful the
video really speaks for itself Xbox sign
out there another close whose name is
xbox sign out oh wait no xbox don't yeah
but to it oh I see why his name is that
I almost signed out do you guys think
this is kind of cruel or just some prime
connect trolling you can let me know in
the comments down below or on my Twitter
where I'm at jeffs McDonald as for
what's on site this week you can check
out my I just got free pizza dance on
the house of horrors watch Danny and Rob
play being cops in GTA Diaries and get
covered up on the very best of 2013
Skyrim mods with sub at camp that's it
from me this week but next week you can
look forward to our US counterparts
taking over for the first couple of
shows as we wait for ed our video
directors to get back in the country
till then I hope you have a great
weekend and I will see you again shortly
we heard a lot about steam machines when
CES roll into town and our full round-up
is on site but here's a quick summary